alors on a une question téléspectateurs
qui donc je pense me concerne je vais
donc la prendre
alors pas tout de suite pas forcément
vos années de l'offre alors je vais vous
répondre je vais vous le dire je vous le
dire voilà s'agir touché exactement à
l'époque 300 mille francs
sakho boas combat 360 300000 france
c'est tout neuf mille francs oui vous
c'était par jour non vous poussez fait
par mois c'est pas vrai c'est quand j'ai
touché 100 mille francs pour l'ensemble
des 5000 euros 45000 euros
cette belle somme c'était un temps un
peu voilà la saison 2 j'avais augmenter
mon cachet un jeu une autre question
alors est il vrai que les employés de
tf1 n'avait pas le droit de regarder le
loft alors c'est une légende qui s'avère
être vraie il se trouve que dans la tour
de parler fin à tant de tf1 il y avait
forcément des [ __ ] millions et je crois
que à 19h le canal numéro 6 été coupé en
compte pour tf1 imaginer la première
fois dans l'histoire de tf1 qu'une
chaîne leur passer devant à 19 heures on
était loin de monde et 6 à 7 millions
tous les soirs c'était il était un peu
comme dirait l'autre un peu hot and haas
une autre question
alors est ce que l'un d'entre vous a
demandé à la production
ah c'est intéressant ce programme et
sont éliminés alors alors moi non
jean rivard non bah non non non cette
vision non plus non plus je pense que ça
s'est fait dans les saisons d'après
j'aime ça non moi non mais je pense que
ça s'est fait dans les saisons d'après
où certains candidats négocier avec la
production je crois pour sortir plus tôt
parce qu'ils avaient des projets à
l'extérieur etc
enfin je crois après ce qui se raconte
que c'est que david qui est sorti et
j'ai très très haut débit de viol avait
on avait un peu oublié voulais rester
mais la production lui a dit qu'il avait
des possibilités à l'extérieur c'est
comme ça qu'ils ont le ciel fait
ressortir ça c'est ce qu'on a compris
qu'il a obtenue une pub
qu'on ne citera pas pour du cola et qui
a marché et en fait on l'a fait sortir
comme ça devient bon parce que les
ayants ils vont me voulait déjà comme
sacha ces jeunes c'est dans la salle des
fêtes avec un chemin c'est jenny white a
rêvé une combine plein essor il a raison
c'est vrai qu'il ne faut pas se mentir
alors il échoue
david était super inquiétant très
inquiétant alors c'est possible que la
production ayant constaté un
comportement pour le moins curieux il
est même trouvé de plus pour rire dit
non je pouvais sortir ça nous arrange